today I look masculine okay today we are
dressing up as men who never heard of
drag Kings before I'm just really
excited about like stuffing and having
just like a huge I don't know I'm so
uncomfortable to dress as a guy and act
as a guy what am i hotter as a dude I
really want to know how they're gonna
contour my face my biggest issue is I'm
wondering where my boobs are gonna go
why do you think no one knows about
dragging so drag is already a subculture
of the traditional gay lesbian and
transactions are the more flamboyant
over-the-top they send out in crowds
more there has been drag kings it's just
not seen as a spotlight it's still a
man's world in us in a way it is even
though they're dressed as women what
inspired you to start doing drag I've
been dancing since I was three they
always made me do the you know the girls
side and I was looking at the guys and
what they were doing how did you like
learn all the makeup skills the
University of YouTube lotta homework I
was born as a woman biologically so I
still do what I have to do to be a drag
king it's just this like alter ego like
amplified persona of yourself
it's whatever you're feeling that day I
was like watching you I was like I'm so
turned on right now
it's insane you're welcome with like the
boobs
where do they go under your armpit they
don't go there there's techniques
they'll get there this is Michael my
boyfriend is gonna be in the crowd I
want to get him so sexually confused
that's gonna be great I think I'm gonna
do it I'm in alright
[Music]
two hours and tell me slay these [ __ ]
like do you fix my ID make my eyebrows
more like mani yes okay men have more
top bro how does it feel to have chest
hair yeah for sure such attention to
detail I love it feel like I just have a
bunch of pubes glued to my face looks
like you look really cool then my
biggest fear was that I'm gonna turn
into a 1970s porn star luckily I'm not
too boobage thinking they're gonna be
gone what do you do again I get corroded
duct tape and I take strips of it and I
cover my nipples with like days or
something and I just going back back
back up back it up back it up back it up
Landon gave me an awesome dick it feels
really cool it's like kind of sexually
excited me being a guy had to figure out
what my name is you have to choose a
name that hits you not just a character
you okay I'm just in ponds up her skirt
so I thought you should know that I
really want to see myself when is this
happening
it's weird cuz I have cramps right now
but I also can feel the make me do so
are you ready yes I'm scared too one oh
my god
wait it looks like you gave me different
bone structure holy SH I look like Ron
Jeremy would I date myself probably what
did you do I didn't have many
expectations so this is really crazy
I look like an Abe Lincoln you'd want to
oh my god I really look like a dude
[Music]
thank you thank you I'm so ready
[Music]
I have the entirely different face I
didn't want Linda messing with my eyes
and I didn't want to Goff my nail-polish
and I'm still just a hundred percent a
Duke interacting with the girls like
grinding on them putting my hat on that
that was so much fun once you get your
sock in your pants you like walk a
different way it was really cool I loved
it I was really really nervous what I
realized that it's just about elevating
parts of yourself that you really don't
get to express in everyday life I could
see the terrified look on my boyfriend's
face but it was awesome to watch it go
from terror to be impressed to like
totally impress to actually have him a
lot of fun so much of it is just the way
you look in your body language and your
eye contact everyone acted like they've
never seen glitter before I thought I
had invented glitter when I did that I
thought it would be pretty easy but it's
really hard and it's really an art to
act like this I think that Freddie
Mercury's looking down on me being like
okay she has my blessing she did a good
job I had talked today game about being
a good looking guy I can like
confidently say like yeah like I would
be a good looking guy I had so many
girls come up to me that they were so
confused like they didn't want to think
I was sexy I achieved my goal I wanted
to turn girls on and they did this is by
far hands down without a doubt the most
eye-opening adventurous than I've jumped
in my entire life not even like one of
them no way to like is the mad love to
all the drag kings you guys work your
asses off and you made us look amazing
they just perform well we all felt like
hot ass dude